California surfer who was bitten by a
great white shark revealing how he
survived Nick Waldner is his name he
says the shark clamped down on his
ankles and legs Tuesday morning yikes
the 19 year old needed about 50 stitches
the attack happened off the central
California coast at Montano de Oro State
Park at a time of year when shark
attacks are rare Jamie yuccas shows us
how Wapner escaped I've never really
thought about this happening Nick Wapner
believes this surfboard likely saved his
life when he says a 15-foot great white
shark came up beneath him as he paddled
toward a wave I just felt like this
tremendous pressure around my ankles and
my legs I was like wow okay this is new
he came up and then nicked this whole
part of my ankle Wapner quickly worked
one of his legs free but not before the
shark's tooth ripped this hole in one of
his booties I was able to get like a
couple kicks in on its head and then it
like maroc to see it let me go his
friends quickly rushed him to the
hospital he says he felt lucky no major
arteries were damaged normally most of
our incidents shark bites on people
occur in the fall so to have an incident
in January is a little unusual in fact
out of the hundred and three california
shark attacks recorded in the past 93
years only three have happened in the
month of January compared with 22 in
October lo says the white sharks are
staying in the area longer because of
warmer waters there it's their world I
mean you're basically trespassing in
their world and it's definitely like a
traumatic experience but I mean I spend
so much time in the ocean and it's such
a big part of my life that I don't think
I'm gonna stop surfing for CBS this
morning
Jamie yuccas Los Angeles you hear this
from so many of the victims that they
still will go back out to the water but
you're not surprised looking at Nick
Wagner are you he's very chilly oh just
the way that he described the shark
biting he goes Wow okay yeah Wow okay
this is new when they took a blood
pressure reading for him when he got
into the air into the hospital how did
they get him yes that was no he's so
chill I like it that would not be my
reaction nor would it be minded
screaming for my dead mother
that point we're glad he's okay yeah all
right